[Musica]
amici buongiorno e ben ritrovati in
realtà ci conosciamo perché siamo tutti
abitanti della stessa casa e cerchiamo
di farci qualche domanda insieme in
questi dieci minuti 11 poi mi faranno
dei gestacci trascineranno via allora
c'è un piccolo problema che dobbiamo
risolvere insieme il pianeta terra non è
infinito il secondo piccolo problema
l'avete le mie spalle mi hanno detto
stamattina che non dovevo presentarlo in
inglese in ogni italiano quindi avrete
una sfasatura cercheremo di tradurre
terra terra può essere la nostra culla e
lo è stata perché siamo nati dai
microrganismi che hanno generato la vita
prima nell'acqua poi nella metro di
terra sotto i nostri piedi ma può essere
anche la nostra tomba può essere la
nostra casa e forse fra le tre io
preferirei la terza dipende da noi
allora dove sta la vita la biosfera
luogo fisico dove sta la vita eco qui
c'è un po di vocabolario dobbiamo anche
imparare se vogliamo occuparci
irresponsabilmente del pianeta terra
dobbiamo capire cosa e dove risiede la
vita risiede in uno spazio molto
ristretto ecco il nostro amico nasca ci
ha dato uno spazio infinito noi invece
lavoriamo su uno spazio piuttosto
ristretto
eccolo lo spazio ristretto 20 chilometri
compresi i 10 km della xi della fossa
delle marianne e circa 10 in atmosfera
quindi la biosfera non è così infinita e
dentro tutto questo ci sta e quello che
noi possiamo chiamare il territorio non
è soltanto il suolo ma è anche
la natura e gli esseri umani che fanno
la differenza
questa è lanciato sfera è diverso perché
perché qui c'è un pezzo di vita un pezzo
di territorio e una identità forte e
tutto questo in km 5 100 metri
ecco non abbiamo un'infinità di tempo e
di spazio per potersene occupare
ecco perché siamo seduti qui oggi
anziché magari trascorrere una giornata
con gli amici
altrove dobbiamo cercare di capire che
cosa fa per noi il suolo fa tante belle
cose che gli esperti di materia
ambientale chiamano i servizi
ecosistemici i servizi eco sistemici
sono tanti e dovremo cercare di essere
un po più pazienti adesso perché così ne
troviamo alcuni alle nostre spalle
innanzitutto il servizio di lavorare per
noi c'è chi senza accorgersene st
rimuginando e rimasticando la nostra
terra
e così il suolo diventa nuovamente
fertile ha proposto di agricoltura e
stato bellissimo sentire
quante cose possiamo fare insieme con il
suolo
ma questo significa procurarci le
materie prime dopo dobbiamo in qualche
modo essere consapevoli che ci sono
altri servizi che invece noi non
conosciamo per esempio la regolazione
dei flussi idrici quando arriva troppa
acqua noi siamo sommersi l'acqua un bene
prezioso qualche volta è scarso
qualche volta esagera e in italia il più
grande servizio che possiamo chiedere al
suolo è la regolazione assorbire il
suolo
ecco perché il secondo tema altrettanto
nascosto ma è altrettanto importante ci
riguarda da vicino avete visto questa
immagine all'inizio di un impianto che
credo in puglia sia abbastanza noto
senza fare necessariamente nomi ma la
cattura del carbonio è un altro
benissimo servizio che abbiamo e tutto
questo si chiama abitati il luogo dove
siamo seduti oggi questo è il nostro
habitat per la nostra giornata
ma domani avremo un altro abitato è
complessivamente si chiama pianeta terra
allora la domanda numero uno forse ce ne
siamo già fatte tante ma perché parla
così tanto questo è la seconda è se ci
stiamo veramente prendendo cura del
pianeta terra nel luogo dove stiamo
avvitando e l'uomo ha fatto tante cose
ha un rapporto piuttosto lungo l'uomo il
genere umano human khalil con il
territorio perché prima lo attraversava
percorreva il territorio
gli esperti di paleoantropologia ci
dicono che hanno fatto un sacco di
chilometri prima non tanti quanti i
satelliti ma comunque parecchi e lo
attraversavano il suono rosse poi hanno
cominciato a usarlo ecco l'agricoltura e
con gli insediamenti urbani ecco il
suolo che diventa un qualche cosa da
consumare e purtroppo ne stiamo abusando
perché quando abbiamo scoperto che
possiamo avere una seconda anno terza
una quarta casa non ci siamo fatti il
problema di consumare lo spazio quindi
il suolo che diventa abusato e
nell'abuso forse ci dimentichiamo che il
suolo e può essere veramente il luogo
dove noi possiamo realizzare noi stessi
questa per esempio è una cosa tanto cara
la puglia perché la regina di tutte le
vie consolari
si chiama appia antica tre secoli prima
di cristo è si cominciava già a partire
da roma per arrivare a brindisi
no a brooke a brindisi allora
l'alternativa può essere il suolo da
consumare o suolo da recuperare da
riscoprire
stiamo riscoprendo lo grazie a tutto
quello che si chiama turismo lento anche
la puglia sta scoprendo questo
riappropriarsi del territorio in maniera
sostenibile
e purtroppo il problema è serio perché
se continuiamo abusare del suolo il
suolo si degrada non si ricostituisce
continuamente e quindi arriviamo al
paradosso che continuiamo a dire che non
dobbiamo tirare i rifiuti buttare i
rifiuti ma continuiamo a riempire il
suolo di rifiuti soprattutto rifiuti
speciali cioè quelli industriali e
soprattutto pericoloso
allora dobbiamo fare un salto di qualità
fare un po un giro un mezzo giro di
questo mondo bellissimo questo cerchio
che si rinchiude dentro uno spazio
limitato vedete anche noi speaker siamo
limitati perché dobbiamo passare dalla
tipica sindrome nimby per favore non è
mio giardino poi fate quello che volete
ma fatelo altrove quindi la trasportare
altrove i risultati negativi nel nostro
consumo di suolo di risorse di plastica
è certa
peccato che la plastica di cui oggi
siamo liberi invece stia affettando stia
colpendo gli oceani con quella che io
chiamo la democrazia della plastica
perché noi la buttiamo lontano da noi ma
prima o poi ritorna perché c'è un
riflusso e siamo pieni di plastica
allora non basta più la sindrome del not
in my back yard
dobbiamo passare a una cultura diversa
quella di non pensare che soltanto gli
addetti ai lavori debbano occuparsi di
bonificare il suolo ecco fra di noi ci
sono tante persone che trascorrono le
domeniche a fare questo
i minuti scorrono velocemente allora
questo invece è un'immagine che dovrebbe
esservi familiare perché è una delle 14
mila cave dismesse in italia senza un
futuro cioè senza un progetto per rifare
e rimettere a posto il territorio allora
il suolo si asporta si muove ma diventa
anche un rifiuto perché scaviamo
scaviamo poi non sappiamo più dove
metterlo e le
le cave abbandonate in italia sono un
problema non solo paesaggistico ma sono
anche un problema molto serio dal punto
di vista della inquinamento del suolo si
possono fare cose molto belle come
questa per esempio riqualificare le cave
risparmiando suolo e quindi
riqualificandole da un punto di vista
ambientale come la logica di economia
circolare con la circolarità del mondo
quei palloni che stavano viaggiando
prima nello spazio cioè invece di
continuare a consumare consumare
consumare prendiamo una cosa ne facciamo
ritornare in vita ecco anche per il
suolo vale questo discorso perché
possiamo usare le discariche per fare il
finto back feeling del riempiono di
nuovo le trasformiamo di nuovo in un
paesaggio ondulato verde ma possiamo
anche riempirle di rifiuti pericolosi ed
è quello che purtroppo sta succedendo in
tutta l'europa
enel nel mondo poi non ne parliamo ecco
allora le discariche illegali sono un
altro grosso problema del pianeta terra
quindi anche un nostro problema si
possono fare delle cose molto belle però
per esempio si può creare un feeling da
un meccanismo cioè una piattaforma di
scambio fra chi scava e non sa dove
mettere la terra e chi ha bisogno di me
prendere la terra per riempire per fare
ripascimenti eccetera che questo è un
esperimento che è stato fatto dall
associazione nazionale costruttori
italiana per esempio nella logica tipica
di ridare vita alle terre e rocce da
scavo e con qualche anno abbiamo anche
delle regole su questo siamo in overtime
non sbaglio allora il suolo è purtroppo
super consumato e quindi in qualche modo
crea movimento anche di persone non solo
di terra
spostiamo la terra spostiamo anche le
persone purtroppo ma le persone possono
anche gli scopi della propria terra e
questa è la riscoperta di un suolo che
dovrebbe esserci molto familiare il
suolo diventa il luogo dove riscopriamo
le tradizioni le valorizziamo questo per
esempio una produzione dop locale
non faccio nomi perché non si possono
fare pubblicità giusto ma
e molto importante essere consapevoli
che tradizione il suolo territorio e
identità sono tutto altrimenti il
rischio è semplicemente di considerare
il suolo e la biodiversità del suolo
come un oggetto di consumo quindi
microorganismi producono e realizzano
tessono queste cose belle e noi ce le
compriamo come souvenir
una volta le compravamo noi adesso le
comprano soprattutto i mercati asiatici
ecco allora mercato ai commerci illegali
tutto questo significa insomma allora
guardate è però anche il lato positivo
delle cose
quindi parliamo sempre male dei mercati
asiatici che consumano il legno lavori
eccetera però questo per esempio è
quello che e cina india stanno facendo
cioè la percentuale di aree del loro
territorio che sono 12 milioni di
chilometri quadrati fra l'uno e l'altro
insomma ci sono anche due miliardi e
mezzo
direi che sono tantini ecco però stanno
ritornando a rendere verde la loro parte
la domanda e noi che cosa facciamo a
proposito di gestione del suolo ecco
come gestiamo la pianificazione dell'uso
del suolo e bisogna rinverdì nel pianeta
nel senso di rinverdire il nostro modo
di pensare
secondo me altrimenti il rischio questo
che il suolo e il paesaggio diventino
semplicemente la deformazione di quello
che noi vogliamo
crolla il suolo e si degrada
completamente il paesaggio è quello che
stiamo vivendo in in italia la
degradazione con il rischio
idrogeologico in cina si fanno le strade
intorno agli alberi per rispettarli e
quindi in qualche modo c'è anche la
saggezza degli alberi e delle radici una
salvezza in qualche modo radicata il
rischio finale c'è una buona notizia sto
arrivando alla fine e che non abitiamo
necessariamente in una catapecchia in
disfacimento
ma in un luogo dove certamente siamo un
po abusatori siamo trascurati degradati
e alla fine qualche modo accettiamo il
declino
beh dipende da noi dipende da che cosa
vogliamo vogliamo una casa vogliamo una
culla su cui lasciarsi cullare nella
bambagia o vogliamo una qualche modo una
abitazione eco finale beh io credo che
dipende da noi se vogliamo tornare a
casa questo mi sembra il luogo giusto
grazie dc
[Applauso]